Hi I am Erik and I am a software engineer
working on Google Chrome extensions.
In this video I am going to talk about the
user interface for extensions.
Google Chrome's user-interface design emphasizes
"content, not chrome" which means we try to
minimize the amount of screen real-estate
the browser UI uses in order to allow the
user to focus more on the content of the web.
For Google Chrome extensions, we wanted to
make sure we preserved Google Chrome's minimalist
aesthetic.
Extensions in other browsers have a reputation
for doing things like filling your browser
with toolbars, or covering every possible
surface of your browser with their UI, leaving
no room for the content itself.
With Google Chrome extensions, we've decided
to take the approach that an extension is
only allowed a single UI surface, and that
UI surface will be minimal.
We also believe that users should control
where and when extension UI is displayed,
so it should be easy to hide and remove any
unwanted user interface.
While developing Google Chrome extensions,
we experimented with a number of other UI
surfaces, and we kept pushing them to make
them simpler and more minimal.
Those that didn't feel like they fit our UI
philosophy were eventually cut.
The content-not-chrome philosophy extends
to the types of extensions that we'd like
to enable as well.
Rather than focusing too much on changing
particulars of Google Chrome's interface,
we've designed the extension system to be
about interacting with the web.
Google Chrome extensions are primarily about
adding functionality to web pages, or providing
access to or integration with the content
from web sites.
They're not about changing the appearance
of the tabs or rearranging the menus.
The simplest bit of extensions UI is the browser
action.
A browser action is a simple button that is
added to the main toolbar to the right of
the omnibox.
The extension can change the icon on the button,
depending on the content on the current page,
even animating it.
Extensions can also simply add colored badges
of text over their icons.
These badges are ideal for counters or small
status indicators.
In addition to simply performing actions,
browser actions can also show popup bubbles.
Pop ups are built using HTML and are sized
dynamically based on the contents.
Page actions are similar to browser actions,
but they're in the omnibox and they appear
and disappear based on the contents of the
page.
Like browser actions, page actions can display
pop ups, but they don't support badges.
The rule of thumb about when to use each is
that a browser action should almost always
be valid - for example, "blog about this page"
or "show the current weather forecast" - , while
page actions should only apply to some pages
based on their content - for example "map
address on this page".
Another approach for extension UI is to use
the content of the page itself.
This can be the ultimate in the minimalist
approach, taking up no space in the browser's
chrome itself.
For example, an extension might turn the results
of an image search into a slide show, completely
using in-page UI.
With the extension system itself, our team
wanted it to feel lightweight and unobtrusive.
For example, when you install extensions,
they immediately appear and are usable.
You're not prompted when extensions update
themselves, and you never need to restart
the browser, even when you disable or uninstall
an extension.
In the future, we will likely provide web
developers with access to more surfaces.
However, we will always do this carefully
with the user's interests in mind. We welcome
your suggestions in our discussion group.
If you are interested to learn more about
Google Chrome extensions visit our website
at code.google.com/chrome/extensions